cut my life into pieces this is my last
resort suffocation no breathing
what
no it's a song about suicide you can't
listen to music that exactly describes
the emotional thing you're going through
you know how cheesy that is
i don't listen to atlanta's more set
when i'm going through a breakup and i'm
not listening to papa roach on the day
i'm going to kill myself
i get that you've been in like a little
bit of a slump lately but suicide's not
the answer to that
i know you think you can solve all your
own problems but that ain't working for
you go talk to someone i'd like to make
a return
this has been a lifelong thing for me
you don't know that things will get
better you tried it kevin and you ended
up in the hospital this time i'm here
we'll do it right we'll do it together i
love you man
you're my best friend i love you too
about on three
one
two two
jesus christ man i need one more day you
just tried to kill yourself three days
ago you had three last days got rice
cooking in the microwave world's our
oyster
any idea we should do with our last day
if i had any ideas i'm gonna ask you to
blow my brains out 35 minutes ago
we're not going to see tomorrow which
means today we get to do whatever we
want with no consequences so let's use
that opportunity to do some good
are you in all right
and it's a great
day to be alive i know the sun's still
shining when i close my mind there's
some hard times in the neighborhood but
why can't everybody
[Music]
[Music]
you